We had another yesterday in the in the rush to get
this first day of Trump's second impeachment trial
out live on all of our platforms. I did not
cover the White House press briefing with Press
Secretary Jen Psaki. And yes, I will address my
pronunciation of Soki in the voicemail segment
today and reporters just. They will not stop
asking really dumb questions. Here is a reporter
asking Jen Psaki, Does Joe Biden plan on hanging
up a painting of Donald Trump in the White House?
Of course, Donald Trump not hanging a painting
of Obama, as is often done of the prior
president. In the midst of everything that's going
on in week three of Joe Biden's administration.
Jen Psaki asked, what about Joe Biden's
view on a Trump painting in the White House?
President Trump, former President Trump, he broke
tradition by not having his predecessor have a
portrait of him. Mm hmm. As far as I can, that was
something that was considered totally the normal
thing to do. Will President Biden inviting
his predecessor to have a future somewhere
and will he get the Obama voters
back in to finally get the ceremony?
I have no portrait revealing or portrait
plans or portrait events to preview for you,
but I have not been given any indication that
we would break with tradition in that regard.
So not a major issue, as you can imagine. I really
don't know what's up with some of these questions.
It's not completely clear to me because they're
not necessarily coming from all from reporters
with with bad reputations or from whom we
would expect this. I mean, Peter Doocy. Yes,
we know what he's trying to do and get sound bites
for right wing media. But some of these are not
reporters that have particularly bad reputations
or are known to have bad, bad intentions. But we
these these questions simply will not stop. Now,
here's a bonus clip. I mentioned Peter Doocy,
a Peter Doocy asking a question. This is just
unbelievable. Irony is dead. Peter Doocy asked
about conflicts of interest for Joe Biden.
You really can't make this up. Joe Biden's son
in law was advising Biden on vaccine response
at some earlier point. Here is Peter Doocy
continuing to try to make a name for himself
with supposedly tough questions of Jen
Psaki. And he brings this up. Take a listen.
Quick one on conflicts of interest and some
reporting that's been done by our colleagues
at other networks. The president's son in law,
Dr. Howard Crane, was advising candidate Biden
on covid-19 response while he was investing
in companies involved with the covid-19
response through his company, Startup
Health. Dr. Crane has been at the White House
since the inauguration. Is he still advising
the president on coordinating the response?
Well, Dr. Crane is his son in law. The president.
There are questions about the potential.
Well, and I think he was here because the
president was inaugurated recently, which is
understandable. The president has made clear that
there will be an absolute wall between him and
any businesses connected with his family members.
And as he reiterated just last week, no family
member is going to have an office in the White
House or be involved in any government policy
making that applies to his son in law and
applies to every single member of his family.
This guy was there for the inauguration. He's
not working for the White House. How can they
pretend to care about conflicts of interest? Now,
we just learned Jared and Ivanka in positions not
confirmed by the Senate nor elected by the people,
were working in the White House and made
between 200 and 600 million dollars while
working at the White House for those four years.
Now, sadly, we expected this. And unfortunately,
it does work on a lot of people. Millions
of Trump supporters who never cared about
conflicts of interest for the last
four years will fixate on this stuff.
And in that sense, it's not stupid for Fox News to
do it for their audience. They look like complete
fools to most of the world and the country.
But for much of their audience, this is how
they generate narratives and create agendas. But
what about what about this what about this vaccine
advice? Where were you when the VANKA was making
millions from handbags and working for Trump and
Kellyanne Conway was promoting the handbags on Fox
News? Where were you then? Well, they were nowhere
because they didn't care. And it's not about
principle. It's merely about what can we say
to try to attack Joe Biden? And unfortunately
for the low information Fox News audience, the
Osborne tapes, the Newsmax types, this may well
be compelling and it's how you generate narrative.